my name is adam cole today we're going
to spatchcock a chicken which basically
just means we're going to remove the
backbone so that the whole thing can lie
completely flat on the grill the brine
we use to impart flavor as well as
retain moisture so the brown sugar in
this case is all about balance for the
same reason you add salt to chocolate
chip cookies we're adding a little bit
of sweetness to our brine to balance the
saltiness you can brine for as little as
four to six hours chickens i like to
brine 24 hours and we've got trash cans
they're nsf approved i make 12 gallons
of brine at a time and brine 32 chickens
and we do that four or five times a week
so the first thing i'm doing is removing
the wishbone
and popping the top out and pulling it
all out in one piece
pistol grip
cut down either side of the backbone
cut around the oyster muscles a lot of
people consider that the most
delicious and decadent muscle on the
entire chicken now i'm removing the keel
bone
i'm looking for
excess skin
you can spatchcock really any bird they
all have the same anatomy so you can
spatchcock a duck you can spatchcock a
guinea hen even turkey at thanksgiving
if you spatchcock a turkey it
dramatically reduces the amount of
cooking time and tends to cook your
breasts and your thighs a lot more
evenly all the way across
we're laying it flat in a way that the
largest amount of skin
is in contact with the grill
people debate all the time over what's
the best barbecue or what region is the
best or what style is the best but when
it comes down to it all barbecue has a
few things in common it's all about
knowing how to build and control a fire
you can make any protein taste delicious
if you know how to control the heat and
the smoke and the temperature it's a way
of cooking that is extremely old you
kind of hear that word barbecue and your
mouth starts to salivate a little bit
it's almost as if it's ingrained in our
dna that's what it's all about